[Music]
foreign
for Friday August 26th I'm Zoe Thomas
for The Wall Street Journal
you've probably heard this before
man
diabetes
that's from the Apollo 11 mission in
1969.
now NASA wants to return to the moon for
another giant leap into the future
here's NASA administrator Bill Nelson
speaking earlier this month it's a
future where NASA will land the first
woman and the first person of color on
the moon
and on these increasingly complex
missions astronauts will live and work
in deep space and will develop the
science and technology to sin the first
humans to Mars Nelson is talking about
the Artemis One mission that's set to
take off from Cape Canaveral Florida on
Monday morning
the uncrewed test flight is kicking off
NASA's efforts to return humans to the
Moon by 2025 but the effort hasn't been
easy and it's far from over joining us
to discuss what we can expect from the
Artemis one trip is our space and
Aviation reporter Micah maidenberg hi
Micah thanks for joining me Hey Zoe
alright so Artemis 1 is scheduled to
take off on Monday morning what exactly
should we expect to happen when it does
so this is a test mission there's not
going to be any astronauts on board but
Artemis one is you know a really
important precursor to that bigger
ambition of taking people back to the
moon so on Monday NASA may try to launch
this gigantic rocket called the space
launch system that has a spacecraft
called Orion stacked on top of it
there's been of course many rocket
launches conducted by SpaceX United
launch Alliance other companies but
nobody has sort of launched to orbit a
rocket this powerful in decades after
the launch happens the main rocket and
the boosters you know Fall Away other
parts of the spacecraft on top are
deployed and roughly around 90 minutes
into the trip another propulsion system
connected to Orion will try to give
Orion like a big push toward the moon
and then Orion has a journey to make you
know to get to an orbit around the Moon
where it will stay for at least six days
maybe maybe a bit longer before its
return trip back to Earth
what is NASA going to be watching for in
this test flight this is a high stakes
test flight for NASA they want to keep
pressing on to those you know flights
with astronauts on board so they are
going to be trying to glean every bit of
data about how Orion the spacecraft SLS
the rocket and all the the sort of
related software and Hardware
uh for launch and operations works you
know one really key sort of test on this
mission is how Orion's crew Capsule
that's where astronauts would be
stationed comes back into Earth so we
know private companies are working with
NASA on this how have the contractors
been performing here particularly
building Artemis Artemis depends on a
lot of the the biggest aerospace
companies in the U.S Boeing Lockheed
Martin Northrop Grumman aerojet
Rocketdyne they're an engine maker in
thousands of smaller suppliers you know
over the years the the NASA Inspector
General has pointed out complications
technical issues challenges that
virtually all the the major you know
contractors have faced those have led to
cost delays timeline delays you know and
the agency and its contractors building
these rockets and spacecraft and related
kind of Hardware I've had to to try to
rest those down and get through those
the Inspector General is really
criticized a number of the contractors
for poorer performance over time and you
know those companies said look we're
we're making adjustments we're improving
you know to help bend down the cost
curve in the future
so Dare I ask how much this mission is
in his cost
from NASA's Inspector General is 4.1
billion for production and sort of
launch operations that's the expected
per flight cost for the first four
Artemis missions not just just this one
and it's a number that the inspector
General is called unsustainable so I
want to take a step back for a second
you know why does NASA want to return to
the Moon after all this time I mean
it'll be over 50 years by the time NASA
sends people back
science and exploration is kind of
broadly the answer you know NASA as as
you said like hasn't been on the surface
of the Moon since 1972 and you know the
agency has had various ideas and efforts
programs over the years to sort of
return to the lunar surface but this
Mission sort of is the the culmination
of an effort that began more than a
decade ago to get back to the
exploration and roots of the agency and
also focus on science I should say also
that you know NASA is talking about this
return to the Moon is a bit different
than in the past you know they want to
get to the moon and eventually create a
more permanent presence there and sort
of use that knowledge to get on to to
Mars
all right so if everything does go right
with Artemis one what comes next after
Artemis 1 is Artemis 2. I mean again
this is a test mission that is meant to
allow NASA and the contractors to get as
much data about the performance of these
vehicles and how they operate in you
know the severe very tough environment
of space ahead of putting astronauts on
that Orion crew capsule possibly in 2024
and of course the 2024 Mission would
send astronauts around a lunar orbit you
know around the Moon bring them back to
Earth and then it's in 2025 that the
agency would attempt
again to transport astronauts down to
the lunar surface bring them back up to
lunar orbit and then you know shoot them
back home back to Earth all right that's
our reporter Micah maidenberg thanks so
much for joining us Micah thanks for
having me Zoe
that's it for Tech news briefing this
week our producer is Julie Chang our
supervising producer is Chris sinsley
our executive producer is Katara Yocum
and I'm your host Zoe Thomas as always
thanks for listening and have a
wonderful weekend
[Music]
foreign